perché sembra che io abbia un fungo
nucleare al posto di capelli che
problema che cazzo parliamo a fare è
sempre così vabbè basta alla prima una
cosa importante
allieva tua hai eva madre tua madre
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono felice ed oggi siamo tornati su
happy with che non è ben pineapple apple
penn ma è più il gioco che chi
sicuramente non ha calcato il cazzo come
quella roba lì va bene partiamo le
scorte sono forte che cosa è successo mi
fate ripartire in realtà ragazzi vi
spiego gli ultimi due episodi presente
che devi stare calmo ma calmo forte ma
dicevo ragazzi gli ultimi episodi o
fatti prima di andare in giappone quindi
ho bisogno di riprendermi un secondo
niente la gara non ce la sto facendo ma
posso anche decidere di prendere la
moneta fermi un attimo perfetto non è
andata come speravo aspetta allora
ragazzi ci deve essere un qualcosa che
non vedo non riuscirci a passare in
mezzo difficile ma ci voleva
l'asp e fermi perché non è possibile che
ci abbia messo così tanto va bene è
possibile niente ragazza abbiamo capito
che fim non ci dovevo giocare neanche
dopo il giappone cielo lasciarlo lì
botto il flip
ah no va bene geniale non so se avete
presenti vito con la bottiglia che si
gira
ecco adesso devo fa la stessa cosa con
steve meraviglioso ma devo farlo
arrivare tipo sulla no perché è perché
si è andata giù bruttezza cola ma
secondo voi ragazzi se la pole deve aver
ucciso una povera zucca non ha fatto
niente
cosa fa è scema ma va bene possibile ma
dai ma era presa fede ma allora mi stai
prendo veramente per il culo c'è magia
ripigliati portiere ce l'ho fatta
non ci vado mai non ce la farò mai più
nella nella storia ma va bene così ben
pineapple carta forbice sasso cosa sono
io contro liu che ho capito quindi devo
malate lui sa già che cosa scelgo le
facciamo sasso sasso era lì che si è
stronzo non vale ben lulu lusek tua
sorella zio e tua sorella qua contro
lamenti insegna fa vj e come si gioca
sulla funziona così tu prendi una
[ __ ] mano
prendi l'altra mano di un'altra persona
e fai insieme alla coppa che sono un
valeva che vedi che cosa stai facendo
deficiente e ovvio che se metto prima al
sasso metti la carta è rincoglionito
forbici forbici che dentro riesco a
mandarla dove voglio stranissimo
stavolta dosi preso bene bene reca a
branzi albo grafia fixed forse è fissato
tua madre zio non questo vai occuparti
forte bravissimo bravis
it easy too much
[Musica]
ah ok salva even you we non va bene ci
provo ma basta a quanti azioni di
osservai ok perfetto
complimenti per la posizione sensuale
non toccarti capezzoli potresti farmi
arrapare lander turche tour cuoio
praticamente hanno fatto un frullatore
in turchese
mi spieghi senso comunque conosco cotto
e frullato quindi possiamo provarci vi
insegno come combattere la freddo e
ragazzi sempre grazie a questo livello
si apra il coperchio innanzitutto open
dopodiché si aggiunge un po di bambini a
caso dopo i bambini si aggiungono le
persone che ti hanno freddo nato nella
vita quindi se due tipe grazie ciao
ragazze la posta e kick ass e questo può
accedere tradimento di mezzo per chi è
caduto il padre di uk cosa c'entra si
aggiunge un cesso che rappresenta
appunto il tuo stato d'animo dopo che se
è stato perdonato e delle angurie con le
zucche bene dopodiché si chiude il
coperchio è si parte con step successivo
ok ma mi sa che devo frullare va beh
frullate mentre il frullatore già aperto
che va bene lo stesso
una volta arrivati a questo punto la
tipa non ride primo e mi sembra
abbastanza ovvio avete finito bene così
vi siete vendicati per la vostra friends
on the pine e machete trony in nove
doveva fare il machete tra possiamo alta
avvertitemi perché non sono preparato
psicologicamente a questa cosa va bene
devo colpire già un mandat a [ __ ]
tutti gli machete e invece è perfetto ci
siamo ragazzi ne mancano due ne manca
uno da fare questo livello così
facilmente c'è impossibile è quanto mi
devo stare zitto e di videogiochi la
posso fare agazzi l'ultimo all'ultimo
machete
ma dai ma [ __ ] ce la posso fare
pian piano ciava tranquilli 2
ok per niente ogni tanto ci mette una
vita e poi alla fine con una spada
l'iveco tutti non è normale sa cosa
batte layer cos'è o un forcone nel bene
ti sei fatto male zio godo
intanto sono uscito ucciderlo sono
ancora vivo cozza cose succedono fatto
ecco perfetto questo dovevo fare sin
dall'inizio ci mette un po a capire
livelli ragazza era molto peggio prima
come possibile vabbè lasciamo perdere
sono trovati di 30 secondi mica quanto
mi fanno incazzare questi farò lo faccio
lo stesso perché non vinco mai perché
passano di solito 29 secondi e 9 decimi
e poi muoio ecco non è stato che è morto
un po prima che bei ragazzi scommettete
che non sono realmente 30 secondi ma
molti di meno non so perché però so che
devi stare calmo zio calmo non è così
difficile grazie liuc che mi dai una
mano in questi momenti difficili brutto
deficiente
e vabbè
[Musica]
ero ancora vivo il gioco non mente mai
non mette mai in every bari bach in
gergo kis alto con uno shock che gli usa
bene usa bene le gambe siccome clara di
heidi vai clara che in realtà non sa che
il nonno diabete non abbia adesso ho
capito every bari cosa stai facendo
avrebbero infatti jobs in a mi chiama
che spinta è zio c'è ma ci stai col
cervello
[Musica]
ok non fate domande stop or die fermati
o muori di fermo subito visto funzionato
da dio dai notai non ho forse ma perché
disse così difficile dove è ferma sta
cosa a hogwarts questa non è all whites
maledizione no no non è difficile forza
scorer tira un po di dal culo che vedi
che ti fermi fantastico e ti chiami
ascoltato mi sposo si e puccio de culo
un millimetro torino mi sono formato che
culo rundown ea via fa vedere una nuova
idea di f quanto è brutta questa cosa mi
taccio l'ansia solo a guardare cos'è
devo girare questa cosa brutta è storta
cos'è
[Musica]
ma che abbiamo capito che c'è il padre
di luke che sta comandando questa cosa
quindi e fake va bene ma cosa fa mai
scema che problemi cha sta tizia devi
calma ma non ballare la tectonic mentre
vai avanti perfetto let's golf
cosa è cosa stavamo ragazzi non capito
niente però babù ok tanto è happy with
my kraft sword robelo questo ma perché
c'è una pala a perché ok e quindi adesso
non posso allora la palla a cosa serve
mettevi due spalle facevi prima no
secondo me se la tiro sull'albero posso
tagliare anche l'albero che la parola no
che culo pagherà
manca solo la spada per non c'ha non ho
veramente
certo che sì oggi tra problemi motori e
tra vista non ci vedi incazzo non
sentirà niente ragazzi sto avendo dei
seri problemi giusto livello aiuto
[Musica]
ok calmo cioè la morte p strana per
spada io abbia mai fatto in tutta la mia
carriera di happy meals però va bene
soldi eros parte 1 mc uomini nei è una
borsa e gli iron così a caso mi sa che
possiamo in 55 uomini queste mandando
regalai nata non si stava muovendo lan
illusione ottica
se stava solo muovendo le ruote ecco
adesso mi sto muovendo fantastico
perfetto salve ma cos'è va bene io non
devo sparare sarà lui in quanto comodo
ragazzi battlefield 1 grazie fratello 67
e la madonna armata
l'esercito faccia un colpo di stato così
get back in the tracks living
bene credo che sia contento rossing
parte 21 addirittura sulla luna c'è chi
è lo sa per litro vorrebbe questo
sbaglio ok
[Musica]
non so perché ho fatto così però questa
è una vagina ai ragazzi che un primo
episodio è stato molto strano perché ho
vinto tutto cosa che non succede molto
spesso quindi segnatevi questo episodio
che è particolare 900 ragazzi cosa se
invece lasciato un commento è un bel
live è capace di facebook e come video
trascrizione se si discute ci vediamo al
prossimo vita ricordatevi volevo dire
penpa in apple apple penn che mi ha
veramente fracassato io non me la
linkate perché mi girano le palle così a
caso va beh